what books had a big impact on your life
that you've read is there any that jump
to mind
that you learned from as a writer as a
philosopher as a mathematician as an
engineer
this is one of these questions where i
always blank out and then when i'm
walking out the door
i'll i'll remember 12. so this is a
random selection that doesn't represent
the top the top ones
um well i mentioned you know gulag
archipelago that's
kind of a hefty and dark but and then it
has a personal connection as well
yeah just yeah because like where you
found the book too right
the time in your life where you found it
yeah who recommended it that's also part
of the story yeah so there's definitely
that there's
you know i circle back to moby dick a
lot um
because we read it in a uh
a really great
english class i had in high school and i
came in with an oppositional
stance because i thought that
the teacher was going to try to talk me
into
having all kinds of highfalutin
ideas about allegory and what does this
mean what's the symbolism
and it turned out that uh
it turned out to be a lot more
interesting and satisfying than that
um what was the first powerful book you
remember reading that like
convinced you that
this form could have depth
was it moby dick was it like in high
school i'm trying to remember well moby
dick was definitely a big one
man i used to read a lot of classics
comics
when i was i don't know if you've seen
these
it's a whole
series of comic books
that um
it was viral you could uh in the in the
back of each comic book was an order
form
you could check some boxes and
fill out your address and mail it in
and more would show up
but it was like
they would do the count of monte cristo
you know moby dick
you know robert louis stevenson robinson
crusoe you know all the sort of classic
books
uh
were they had put into comic book form
it's amazing yeah reading moby dick if
you're nine years old
is a tall order
there's some very complicated sentences
in there
um
and a lot of digressions but if you're
just looking at the comic books like
holy [ __ ] look at that whale you know
um
and um and ultimately the power of the
story
doesn't need the complicated words
it's it's all about the man and the and
the whale yeah yeah so you could get
kind of a grounding in a lot of classic
works of literature without actually
reading them which is you know
it's great when you're nine years old
so so i read a lot of that stuff
you